on voit qu'on a parfois des sornettes
sur votre santé contre ces foutaises ces
balivernes
c'est calembredaines et ces billevesées
un homme s'est dressée il est de retour
et il est seul contre tous les médecins
le déteste
non pas d'un grand mère le déteste mais
n'ont pas fait c'est quoi cette histoire
et je m'entends mais avec les grands
mères à les médecins bon ok alors il
s'entend bien avec tout le monde mais il
a des trucs à dire voilà là d'accord dès
le retour du mythe ou buster
c'était déjà livré à l'exercice ya
quelques temps on remet ça aujourd'hui
c'est l'heure de démonter quelques
mythes et quelques mito sur la santé
c'est parti je sais par là on attrape un
rhume à cause du froid et des courants
d'air alors le rhume c'est une maladie
c'est une infection des voies
respiratoires supérieures qui est causée
par un virus et ce virus se transmet par
la salive ou les sécrétions
respiratoires soit par contact direct
vous voyez ce que je veux dire un soin
de façon aéroportée non aéroportée ça
veut juste dire transportés par l'air
transporté par n'importe quel type baer
pas juste l'air froid ou des courants
d'air la seule raison pour laquelle il
ya plus de rhume
l'hiver c'est qu'on reste tous enfermés
à l'intérieur les uns contre les autres
fenêtres fermées et donc on se refile
plus facilement nos gerbe
c'est tout bon alors oui quand il fait
froid on a le nez qui coule c'est vrai
mais c'est juste parce que la muqueuse
est agressé donc elle sécrète plus de
mucus et qui coulent vers l'avant au
lieu de couler vers l'arrière dans les
fosses nasales comme d'habitude mais ça
cool propre parce que c'est pas infecté
donc c'est pas une maladie d'ailleurs ça
s'arrête quand on se met au chaud manger
du poisson ça améliore la mémoire le
poisson s'est plaint de phosphore donc
c'est bon pour la mémoire voulait déjà
entendue celle-là non alors non est ce
que le poisson contient beaucoup de
phosphore oui c'est pas faux mais moins
que le fromage est pas plus que la
viande ni que le vin donc dans l'absolu
une bonne vieille raclette c'est
infiniment plus riches en phosphore que
du vieux poisson bouillie tous les goûts
un jeu me passa le poisson c'est comme
ça
bon mais il faut ce fort alors est ce
que c'est vraiment bon pour la mémoire
non parce que apparemment il y en a
plein dans le vin vous je sais pas mais
moi les lendemains de soirées
je me rappelle pas de tout eh ben non
c'est une vieille croyance des années 70
sans réel fondement scientifique
mais manger du poisson quand même c'est
plein d'oméga 3 à la soupe
ça fait pas grandir non plus les poils
rave et repousse plus drus raser les
poils ça les frères pousser plus vite
plus épais plus fort plus nombreux plus
cruel plus en fait la seule chose qui
change entre l'épilation et le rasage
c'est que dans le
premier cas on arrache le bulbe du poil
donc il doit recommencer à pousser 2 0
du coup un il met plus de temps à
réapparaître à la surface de la peau
donc ils poussent pas moins vite
il part juste de plus loin et 2 c'est un
poil 9,1 avec sa forme de poils qu'on
connaît bien
alors que quand on leur rase le poil et
les couper net parfois même un peu en
biseau du coup le bout et pointue et
comme en plus il est très court donc pas
très souple ça pique un crs mais il
n'est pas plus drue ah oui et si les
adolescents ont la barbe et les poils
des gens qui poussent de plus en plus à
partir du moment où il commence à les
raser c'est juste parce que c'est le
concept de la puberté
en fait c'est les poils poussent de plus
en plus rasage ou par hasard le
gingembre c'est aphrodisiaques
bon alors là c'est un peu plus compliqué
le gingembre depuis des siècles et dans
tout un tas de culture c'est réputé pour
être aphrodisiaques
mais avant de savoir si ça l'est
vraiment on va se mettre d'accord sur
les termes quand on cherche à prodige
yak dans le dico voilà ce qu'on trouve
se dit d'une substance propre à exciter
le désir sexuel
alors est ce que j'ai un jambon excite
le désir sexuel eh bien il n'existe
aucune étude scientifique qui démontre
que ce soit le cas pas plus a priori que
pour n'importe laquelle des autres
substances censées être aphrodisiaques
d'ailleurs aphrodisiaques c'est même pas
une vraie propriétés pharmacologiques
donc scientifiquement c'est non mais bon
le sexe n'est pas de la science alors si
vous aimez bien le gingembre et que vous
avez l'impression que ça vous fait des
guilis dans le bas ventre vous privez
pas on n'utilise que 10% de notre
cerveau on sait même plus de nous vient
cette très vieille croyance mais ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'on a très envie d'y
croire
drake a très facilement le cerveau un
qui on a bien envie de croire qu'on
n'est pas complètement à fond encore en
fait on sait pas vraiment quel
pourcentage de notre cerveau on utilise
mais l'imagerie par résonance magnétique
a démontré que toutes les zones du
cerveau étaient actives justes elles le
sont pas en même temps d'ailleurs notre
cerveau utiliserait environ 20% des
ressources énergétiques de notre
organisme
alors c'est trop peu pour que tout
fonctionne en même temps de toute façon
je sais pas si vous imaginez le bordel
mais c'est quand même beaucoup
non pour un truc qu'on utilise
4 10% il faut se couvrir quand on a de
la chèvre quand on a de la fièvre il
faut se couvrir et bien transpiré 1
on sait pas trop pourquoi mais on l'a
tous entendu là-bas non non non ça sert
à rien et en plus c'est même dangereux
surtout pour les jeunes enfants et pour
les personnes âgées qui risquent de se
déshydrater très rapidement quand on a
de la fièvre
il faut la faire baisser mais pas trop
vite en plus des médicaments type
paracétamol il faut régler son chauffage
à une température jean retour de 18 19
degrés est resté habillé de façon
normale
il faut surtout boire beaucoup d'eau
pour compenser les pertes pour les
enfants les pédiatres recommandent de
prendre leur température et leur donner
un bain de 2 degrés en dessous pendant
une dizaine de minutes
mais si vous êtes adulte et que vous
aimez les bains bah vous privez pas
voilà détester c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui si vous avez d'autres mythes
et d'autres mythos a démonté dites moi
ça dans les commentaires on se retrouve
très bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo
d'ici là mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]